MONEY TO WOMEN WILLING TO
ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT OF
PRIOR HARASSMENT.
AT THE VERY LEAST, BLOOM
ENGAGED IN A PERVERSE KIND
OF FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO
ATTRACT ACCUSERS.
TRUTH BEING, PERHAPS, A
SECONDARY CONSIDERATION.
NOW BLOOM IS GOING ON THE
ATTACK, SMEARING THE
REPORTER WHO BROKE THE
STORY, JOHN SOLOMON OF "THE
HILL" CALLING HIM A FAR
RIGHT JOURNALIST.
YEAR.
HE JOINS US NOW WITH HIS
SIDE OF THE STORY.
JOHN, YOU FAR-RIGHT
JOURNALIST.
A.P.
STORIES ABOUT RAPE IN THE
CONGO ALL THOSE YEARS AGO.
BY THE WAY, IN LAW SCHOOL I
HAD A LICENSE PLATE THAT
>> Laura: EVERYONE THOUGHT
IT WAS VERY FUNNY.
SHE IS ON THE ATTACK SAYING
THAT YOU ARE DISTORTING WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION.
>> I LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO
IF YOU CAN'T ATTACK THE
FACTS DO YOU AD HOMINEM
ATTACK ON THE REPORTER.
THE ATTACKS ARE
UNASSAILABLE.
IT'S TRUE EVEN THOUGH SHE
SAID SHE REPRESENTED WOMEN
BY SELLING THEIR STORY TO
THE TABLOIDS.
ARRANGED FOR DONORS POSSIBLY
RELATED TO THE ELECTION TO
PAY THESE WOMEN MONEY ONE OF
THE WOMEN DESCRIBED A LOT OF
ELECTION DAY GOT NEARER FOR
HER TO COME OUT AND MAKE
THESE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
TRUMP.
THOSE ARE THINGS NOT THIS
DISPUTE.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT LISA
BLOOM TOLD JOY REID OVER THE
WEEKEND.
COME FORWARD.
WE HAVE UNEQUAL PLAYING
FIELD HERE.
ARRANGING FOR SECURITY AND
RELOCATION SERVICES FOR ANY
WOMEN WHO WANTED IT I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR.
EITHER HILLARY CLINTON NOR
ANYONE FROM HER CAMPAIGN WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY OF THOSE
OFFERS FOR RELOCATION AND
SECURITY.
>> Laura: JOHN NO, ONE FROM
THE CAMPAIGN, MILLER DIDN'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT WHAT
LITTLE FACT TODAY DID
LITTLE FACTOTODAY DID
>> SUPER PACS CAN TAKE A LOT
MORE MONEY.
SHE WILL NOT ANSWER THE
CAN'T GET AN ANSWER.
>> Laura: SHE DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT MORTGAGE PAYMENT FOR
THAT HOUSE IN QUEENS.
>> ONE OF THE WOMEN GOT
OFFERED $750,000.
CAN YOU BUY THE SECRET
THERE WAS OTHER PROTECTION.
ONE WOMAN WANTED MORTGAGE
PAID.
THE OTHER WANTED COLLEGE
TUITION FOR KIDS PAID.
A LOT MORE THAN SECURITY.
>> Laura: EMAIL YOU BROKE
SOME TYPE OF MISCONDUCT.
THIS IS WHAT SHE WROTE.
SHE WROTE TO TRUMP'S
THERE THAT I WOULD BE
WILLING TO SAY AT A RALLY OR
SOMEWHERE HOW TRUMP HELPED
ME WITH MY SELF-CONFIDENCE
AND ALL -- THIS IS FROM A
WOMAN WHO SUPPOSEDLY WAS
GOING TO COME OUT, CAME OUT
AND SAID HE MISTREATED ME
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> IN BETWEEN HER TWO
ACCUSATIONS THERE IS A MUCH
GREATER CONTEXT TO THIS
EMAIL.
SHE WANTED A JOB WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
SHE ASKED TO BE HIS CAMPAIGN
YOU ACTUALLY FILE A SUIT
THEY ULTIMATELY DROP.
YOU OBVIOUSLY CAN'T LIKE HIM
ALLEGEDLY DID THIS.
THEN SHE WANTS TO WORK IN
THE CAMPAIGN?
ARTIST?
>> MORE THAN THAT SHE WANTED
HIM TO BE THE PITCH MAN FOR
NEW COSMETIC.
BEAUTY PRODUCT LINE.
YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: SHE CAME OUT AND
SAID TONIGHT OH, I HAD
GOTTEN OVER THE PRIOR, BUT
SHE WAS MAD THAT DONALD
TRUMP SAID IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Laura: THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> IF YOU FOLLOW HER STORY,
SHE WAS ANGRY AT HIM, THEN
NOT ANGRY AT HIM.
>> Laura: DO MY MAKEUP LINE.
I DON'T LIKE YOU.
>> WORK OUT A BUSINESS DEAL
>> Laura: LISA BLOOM SAYS
NONE OF THIS COVERS THE FACT
>> NONE OF THE WOMEN WERE
ASKED.
ALL OF HER PRO-TRUMP STORIES
DOWN FROM FACEBOOK SO THEY
WOULD BE MORE BELIEVABLE.
SO THAT DID HAPPEN.
>> Laura: THEY WEREN'T TOLD
SAY THIS AND I WILL GIVE YOU
X AMOUNT OF MONEY.
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> Laura: SO GOOD TO TALK TO
A FAR RIGHT JOURNALIST